Це - перший у світі безпілотний трамвай.
Ситуацію на дорозі він оцінює завдяки радарам, сканерам і камерам,
які передають інформацію у бортовий комп’ютер.
Трамвай може розпізнавати пішоходів, автомобілі,
сигнали світлофора і дорожні знаки.
також зупиняється на потрібних зупинках
і чекає, поки усі пасажири зайдуть до салону.
На відміну від регіонального та міжміського транспорту або метро,
більша частина маршруту трамвая пролягає звичайною міською трасою
- з пішохідними переходами, велосипедистами.
І навчити його правильно реагувати в різних ситуаціях,
які можуть виникнути - це справжній виклик.
Ситуації, які можуть виникнути на дорозі
під час руху безпілотного трамвая,
вивчали ось у цій лабораторії в Берліні.
Для цього там створили модель випробувальної траси.
Звісно, усе треба спершу протестувати в лабораторних умовах.
Це неможливо зробити на дорозі, оскільки це складно і небезпечно.
Тому все, що пізніше відбуватиметься під час руху,
моделюється та перевіряється тут, у лабораторії.
Трамвай їде самостійно, але в кабіні поки присутній водій,
який у разі виникнення екстрених ситуацій
може взяти кермування на себе.
Проте експерти переконані -
система цілком безпечна.
За багато років ми озирнемося назад і скажемо:
нічого собі, це було початком тривалого розвитку!
У далекому майбутньому машини зможуть їздити повністю автономно.
Але зараз ми усвідомлюємо, що у дечому людина поки краща.
Розроблена нами технологія, функціонує дуже добре,
особливо в тих місцях, де ми відносно незалежні від трафіку.
І навіть у зонах перехресть
ми набагато надійніші, ніж вважалося раніше.
Поява такого транспорту на дорогах, як розраховують
у міській владі Потсдама, дозволить впорядкувати рух
і знизити кількість ДТП.
Проте коли саме безпілотні трамваї
запустять в експлуатацію, поки невідомо.